[Music]
this is all that's left of the infamous
Berlin Wall some graffiti and neglected
grass these two men born in what was
then East Germany helped bring it down
Paul and Yann on the left was extradited
to West Germany he helped get footage of
the East German protests on to West
German television and andreas Rost
protested when doing so was still
extremely dangerous does this pinkish
hangs on the cement the fall of the
Berlin Wall was not a gift it was
something people achieved they toppled
the dictatorship and can be proud of
this the small challenges we face today
are nothing compared to this but andreas
Rost disagrees fundamentally the Leipzig
photographer documented the radical
transformation of East Germany his
pictures show the effects of Germany's
rapid reunification and what was
effectively East Germany's submission to
the West West Germany insisted on its
own way of doing things
most East Germans lost their jobs and
the country they had lived in vanished
we lost all faith and everything to do
with the East we thought West German
milk and sugar was better than our own
even their people were superior many
West Germans wanted to profit for
example those who judged one of East
Germany's beauty pageants it was held in
Leipzig just two months after the Berlin
Wall came down as a demise quiet back
then I was shocked by how these human
bodies were suddenly being exploited for
capitalist game looking at these
pictures today they seem like an
allegory of East Germany's demise these
are not illegal we often tell young lady
now default on Z showing them art the
ladies got dressed up gave everything
they had to and this fat stupid jury
just sat there smoking cigars grading
them
everything had begun so well crowd
shouted we are the people Roland and
andreas met on October 9th 1989 at the
most decisive rally at the time just one
month before the Berlin Wall came down
[Applause]
this footage was shot by friends risking
a lot I smuggled cameras into eastern
Germany my friends took off the secret
police and climbed the lights in church
[Applause]
the army had taken up positions in the
side streets backed up by tanks East
Germany was on the verge of civil war
for some reason we were pushed to the
front to the front row that hasn't been
our plan when the protest march started
we linked arms as we had seen people do
in the movies we thought that's just
what you do
but after a while we realized that the
police and the army we're not
intervening they just let us march the
next day footage shot by Roland's
friends ended up on the West German news
it became obvious East Germany's days
were numbered
journalists were part from reporting
from Nasik
protesters didn't know foreign reporters
could capture this footage 70,000 took
to the streets one of the first East
German leaders to fall was Irish mukha
head of the secret police the Stasi from
his headquarters he had overseen a vast
informers Network never would he have
imagined that his office would one day
be a tourist attraction he used this
safe to store compromising documents on
East German leader Erich Honecker one
card is no standing in Irish milkers
former headquarters makes clear just
what great symbolic meaning this has we
have visitors from 40 different
countries who admire Germany for having
toppled the dictatorship and for being
this brave it sends a strong signal and
creates home today Roland Yan is in
charge of East Germany Stasi files he
shows us the cellar where there are
endless rows of them Germany was able to
salvage most of them making them
accessible to former victims of the East
German regime andreas Rost appreciates
this former East German Communist Party
members and informers were not treated
with leniency after the fall of the wall
but he thinks other big mistakes were
made to this day many East Germans feel
they are not treated equally and he says
it was recognized too late that eastern
Germany has a problem with right-wing
extremism and xenophobia Jesus musn't
this for at first we chanted we are the
people then we are one people okay which
is still acceptable but when this change
into the belief that foreigners should
leave Germany something definitely went
wrong the Berlin Wall came down 30 years
ago but to this day the country still
isn't truly United that will take more
than one generation
[Music]